عوده الى الاخبار العاجله بشان اوكرانيا
بدبابات ثقيله بعد ان قالت وكاله الانباء
الالمانيه ان المستشاره الالماني وافق على
تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات ليفرد القتاليه
زمن هذا ايضا مع تاكيد مسؤول الامريكيه
للجزيره من البيت الابيض حسب قراره بتزويد
اوكرانيا بدبابات ابرامز وقد قتل الاعلان
الرسمي قد ياتي ربما الاعلان الرسميه
الامريكيه
لحظه ينضم الينا من عمان اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتي
سيد لواء مغزى همم القرار الامريكي
والالماني
المتزامن بتزويد دبابات ابرامز الامريكيه
همم الى اوكرانيا ولو برده الالمانيه الى
يعني من اسبوع تقريبا والمباحثات بين
البلدين في مستوى عالي ومكثف اشترى
اشتراطات المستشار الالماني ان المانيا
ستقدم دبابات اليو بارك اذا قدمت امريكا
دبابه ابرامز ثم جاء القرار الالماني
بالسماح للدول التي تمتلك هذه الدبابات ان
تقدمها لاوكرانيا دون اذن من المانيا ثم
جاء التوافق الامريكي
الالماني على تقديم دبابات يوبارد ودبابات
ابرامز واعتقد ان هذا ياتي من خلال قراءه
مستفيظه لميدان المعركه واحتياجاته
وما هي المعارك المحتمله مع بدايه الربيع
الكل يتوقعه هجوم في روسي في الربيع والكل
يتوقع ان تكون دائره الاشتباك واسعه
منخار كيف شمالا حتى اوديستا جنوبا وهل
هذه الدبابات ستحدث فارقا على في المعارك
على الارض رايك
يعني الان هذا يعتمد على امرين الامر
الاول مستوى التدريب والتاهيل وقد بدات
الاطم همم الاوكرانيه بالتدرب على دبابه
اليوبارد منذ فتره قريبه
ودبابه اليوبارد لا تحتاج الى تدريب لامد
طويل لانها دبابه اقرب الى الدبابات الجيل
الثالث التقليدي فيما دبابه ابرامز اكثر
وتطورا وتعديدا وكفاءا وتحتاج الى فتره
ليس بالقصيره قد تاخذ اشهر هذا الشوط
الاول الشوط الثاني
الانظمه همم الجيوش العالميه من حيث
التنظيم للفرق المقاتله وفرق الدروع
تقريبا تحديدا متباينه لكن معظم الدول
باستثناء الجيش الامريكي هناك قاسم مشترك
كتيبه الدبابات هي اصغر يمكن ان تنفذ
عمليات مستقله وفي معظم الحالات يعني دعني
اذا سمح الوقت شيء من التفصيل كتيبه
الدبابات كتنظيم ثلاث سرايا دبابات لكن في
القتال هي سريتين دبابات بصريه اليم مدرعه
دائمه فبالتالي كتيبه الدبابات للتنظيم ما
بين 33 الى 35 دبابه اللواء ما بين 66 الى
70 الفرقه سيكون الرقم اكثر من ذلك الضعف
اللواء يعني اشير الاشاره الامريكيه
والمطالبه الامريكيه باعاده توجيه
العمليات باتجاه الجنوب هذا يعني حاجه
لهذا السلاح ويجب ان لا يقل عن حجم فرقه
مدرعه اذا ارادوا احداث تغير استراتيجي
فاعل يستطيع اهداف اختراقات عميقه في همم
في قلوب فبالتالي هذا يحتاج الى مربعات
الفرقه المدرعه ليس اقل من 140